Take a look at the room around you and ask yourself a simple question.
What do you think is the most complex system that stores the most information?
Maybe there's a computer in the room, maybe there's a tablet, maybe you're streaming
this on your cell phone. Are those the most complex systems that store vast amounts
of information? You know, the answer to that is clearly no.
The most complex system in the room is you.
In fact, to be specific, it's your DNA.
DNA stores information, much of the information that makes you,
you. In fact, DNA has greater storage capacity than any
technology humans have ever created.
Take for example just one gram of DNA.
It has roughly the storage capacity of half a million movies.
Now that blows your smartphone away.
your body is made up of around 100 trillion cells the DNA in
one cell in your body just one cell if they were unwound would be about nine feet in
length that means all the DNA in your body strung together would go from here to the
Sun and back about 70 times this raises a very troubling and
difficult question both for naturalism and for pantheism what can best
explain the source of this vast amount of information?
What worldview best explains the origin of DNA?
To explain the rise of information that we see in nature, some naturalists have
devised a test simply called the monkeys typing Shakespeare theorem.
And the idea is if you have a bunch of monkeys and enough computers and enough time,
eventually one of the monkeys will sit down through a purely blind lucky process and
type out all the works of Shakespeare.
The idea is to try to explain the rise of information in nature and in DNA
specifically through a purely blind process.
In my book, Understanding Intelligent Design my co-author William Dembski and I
cited a quantum computational physicist by the name of Seth Lloyd.
What Seth Lloyd did is mathematically compute exactly how much information
could arise by chance given all the resources of the universe.
What did he conclude? Well he concluded that chance alone, again with all the
resources of the universe, could not produce all the works of Shakespeare, couldn't
produce one work of Shakespeare.
Not a chapter, not a page, not a paragraph.
All the resources of the universe by chance at best could produce four lines
from one work of Shakespeare. To be or not to be, that is the question.
Whether 'tis nobler in the mind to suffer.
Some time ago some students and a professor decided to actually test the monkeys
typing Shakespeare theorem. So they took some monkeys put them in a zoo with some
old computers and typewriters to see if one of the monkeys would sit down and type
out Romeo and Juliet or Hamlet. Well what happened?
First monkey picked up a rock climbed up on the computer and tried to bash it.
Some other monkeys climbed up on top and actually went to the bathroom on the
computer. But before you discount this experiment, you know what happened?
Actually in the time that they were in there these monkeys produced roughly six
pages of written text. A string of A's, L's, M's,
J's and an occasional S. Not a single word.
in reality whenever we come across information and can trace it back to its causal
source we always find a mind in fact imagine you come visit me in Southern
California and we go walking on the beach and we walk along and all of a sudden we stop
because we see engraved in the sand a heart that says Sean loves Stephanie
Stephanie is my wife now I know none of you would stop and go well that's crazy I've
heard about earthquakes in Southern California but I had no idea when the ground
shook messages arose from the deep none of you would stop and try to explain that
message by tides or the water or the wind in some fashion you
would know that the only plausible explanation for those markings is an intelligent
mind
we know this in our daily lives whenever we see information at its source we find
a mind for example you get a text and it's legible trace it back to a texter look
at the information in a book trace it back to an author read a blog and you trace it
back to a blogger if you go outside and the clouds say drink Coke none of you think
oh my goodness a storm is coming from the east rather you know that that information
was put there by an intelligent mind in this case by a pilot.
We find more information in DNA than in anything humans can invent.
That's why the best explanation for DNA we see in nature and in the human body in
particular is that it comes from an intelligent designer, an author of life.